this program is brought to you by Emory
University I'm Jan love I'm dean of the
candler school of theology and I am one
of 300 faculty on this campus who are
vitally interested in religion as a
scholarly pursuit and or a teaching
pursuit that's pretty remarkable because
you may realize if you've been on other
research one University campuses that
most of them are indifferent to if not
allergic to religion both in its
scholarly pursuit as well as its
practice and I maintain and haven't been
contradicted convincingly yet that Emery
is unique in higher education and
neither being embarrassed by or
indifferent to religion but really quite
the opposite being vitally interested in
religion as both a scholarly pursuit as
well as a practice and that's evident in
our religious life experiences through
the Dean of the chapel and religious
life and it's evidenced by the more than
300 scholars who are actively pursuing
research and teaching in that area this
afternoon you have two of the most
famous and really quite the most
remarkable before you and it would not
at all be a waste of time to take many
minutes delving into their remarkable
careers and explaining their many
accomplishments you can read some of
those in your introduction and since we
have only a few minutes more than an
hour I'd much rather have them display
their wisdom and their insights to you
and we will begin with Luke timothy
johnson
and then followed by Abdullah he imed on
name so you're in for a treat they will
each present for about 15 minutes and
then we'll have a conversation and I
very much look forward to that thank you
again for coming Luke it's all yours
well thank you hi how y'all doin I like
to begin every session like this by
thinking a little bit about the title
and how I understand the title religion
in the changing world ancient and modern
by religion I mean a way of life
organized around experiences and
convictions having to do with ultimate
power and I think in today's world
people who organize their lives around
such convictions and experiences
concerning ultimate power don't
represent a marginal but a way of life
but a central way of life and it's not
less significant in this changing world
but if anything it's more significant
than ever the keywords to consider here
are ancient and modern and what I want
to do is not take these as chronological
markers that is as long ago and far away
or what's happening now but rather take
ancient and modern as two distinct ways
of looking at the world that are both
operative today in different ways what I
mean by the ancient are people who view
the world in a pre enlightenment or
extra enlightenment fashion and this
view of the world is held by most people
throughout history and most people in
the world today by modern I mean people
who have been shaped by the peculiar
experience of the Enlightenment so they
are enlightenment or post-enlightenment
folks of Western Europe the Americas and
that surface of the world's population
which is connected by global commerce
and communication the
thisis i would like to present to you
today is that ancient modern conceptions
of religion are in conflict and this
conflict is of enormous importance for
our changing world and is in fact
changing our world let me characterize
the two views the modern view is held by
folks like us the most highly educated
the wealthiest and also the smallest
portion of the world's population above
all those of us who have been defined by
that peculiar phenomenon the American
experience of the separation of church
and state how do we view religion what
are the premises we bring to religion
it's private it's a matter of
individuals its interior it's a matter
of individual conscience religion should
be reasonable and governed by reason
rather than by an authority from above
revelation is relative not absolute it's
found among all peoples and not just in
some people religious scriptures are
historically conditioned and they need
to be understood metaphorically or
symbolically rather than literally and
normatively above all above all religion
is not political that the American
experiment as we well know sets out to
separate religion and politics in a very
real way now what are the virtues of
this modern way of looking at religion
while it places a very high premium on
Liberty on the right to follow one's own
conscience so religious rights and human
rights are closely connected liberty of
worship liberty of belief is what the
modern perspective stands
for the second grade virtue is that of
tolerance for difference those who are
different are respected even embraced
and then of course there are the
pleasures of ambiguity we you know we we
enjoy being overeducated not being
certain about everything we like the
relative more than the absolute the
reason why we are educated is that we
enjoy having things measured by reason
so this is a very real set of premises
it is probably the set of premises
shared by mainline Protestantism by
liberal Roman Catholicism both of which
are died in a way the tendency of this
modern perspective is to move toward
spirituality rather than religion so
it's the Oprah version I'm spiritual not
religion or simply toward secularism as
such I mean the drift is very much in
that direction the perspective on the
other way of viewing religion the
ancient view is that what's wrong with
those people they must be B'nai today
haven't caught on they are under evolved
they are fanatic they're not really
religious so it's important for us to
look at the other side of the ancient
conceptions of religion where do these
come from they come from antiquity and
they have been the dominant perspectives
on religion since the ancient imperial
orders of antiquity including the Greek
Empire the Roman Empire these are the
premises that dominated christened dumb
that peculiar form of Christianity and
politics that dominated Western Europe
it is the certainly the premises that
have dominated in Islam as well what are
these premises religion is not private
it's public
it's not about the individual is about
the stage it's about politics it's not
about internal conscience it's about
community and conformity and ritual and
law these are the most important things
religion as stabilizing and maintaining
the world in response to God revelation
is particular rather than universal it
is divine it's not relative its absolute
the sacred writings are to be understood
literally they are normative in every
respect they are not historically
conditioned to read them simply
metaphorically or symbolically is to
show simply that one has not taken them
seriously and religion is to be measured
by authority rather than human reason to
measure religious experience and
convictions by human reason is to betray
oneself as armed not seriously religious
what are the virtues of this perspective
if the modern view places the highest
premium on liberty this place is the
highest premium on truth and the
absolute value of truth rather than this
the liberation of the individual it is
the stability of the social order and it
has the benefit of certainty and in this
view heresy has no rights the tendency
of this view is to demonize those who
disagree with one's view of the truth
and at the ultimate extreme to engage in
holy war of one sort or another we tend
to get upset at a holy war among Muslims
these days we forget Christianity has
had a long and in glorious history of
religious war driven precisely by the
premises that I have tried to enumerate
now if this makes sense in terms of
broad constructions of ancient & mod
views of religion where is the conflict
most powerfully located in today's world
it would be a mistake I think to think
of this as a religion against religion
conflict is not a matter of islam vs
Christianity or Judaism versus
Christianity the conflict is within
religious traditions that is really
where the battle is being fought
certainly within Islam absolutist claims
have been in ascendancy but also in
Christianity in the United States today
the two forms of Christianity that are
growing the fastest that are most
powerful are evangelical Protestantism
and forms of fundamentalism and
conservative even reactionary Roman
Catholicism these are the two forms of
religion each of which shares the
premises of antiquity rather than of
modernity on each of which defines
itself in terms of absolute truth
certainty and high standards of external
performance rather than internal
conscience and liberty now why is this
battle uneven in other words why are why
is the ancient conception of religion
going to win besides the fact that
modern are outnumbered I mean it's quite
serious the vast majority of people in
the world hold with ancient conceptions
of religion I I think it's it's it's
because let me give an example the way
in which it's possible to view others
and speak about others in the ancient
conception which is governed by
certainty one can speak about others in
terms of light
and darkness with the light all on one
side and the darkness all on the other
side one can speak of the angels and the
demons with the demons all on one side
and the angels all on the other side one
can divide the world between truth and
falsehood one can engage in pala make or
attack on those who belong to the other
tradition one can engage in prostitution
trying to convert others to one's view
is a matter of rescuing people from
demonic forces you are trying to save
them for the truth now this level of the
view of the world is filled with
incredible energy and passion and and it
is it is easily it's easy to get behind
such a program of self certainty know
huh okay it's in the bag Janet's if I'm
right here I'm in the final turn
four minutes although I do well with
authority no modern me now just really
I'm very close to bein they contrast
that level of energy passion and
certainty not to mention numbers with
the posture that those of us who are
modern in our religious perspectives
take toward others it is characterized
by ambivalence it is a matter of
humanism it is a matter of inclusion it
is a matter of you say that truth is
found everywhere we're very careful
about trying to proselytize others we
just want to bear a quiet witness we
want to affirm the religious traditions
of others rather than to change them or
to overcome them modern religion is
filled with ambivalence and anxiety
rather than certainty and passion so I
want to conclude with three points about
those of us who represent the modernist
in religion the first is I don't think
we should give up on the Enlightenment I
think it's a really really good thing
and I think it's actually the better
position with regard to religion
secondly though we ought not to be so
parochial and naive as to think that
everybody thinks the way we do and that
the other perspective is held only by a
few people that who haven't been
sufficiently educated we need to
understand secondly the scope of the
battle in matters of religion
unfortunately liberalism never wins
conservatism almost always wins in the
long run and the more we deal we face
that if
third I think those who represent
modernity in religion need to try to
recover some of the values that are
represented by the other side of the
value of community the value of practice
a concern for truth and above all
passion thank you as you could see I'm
from Sudan okay so I in fact i am from
Saddam but I have been at Emory longer
that i have been at any other place in
my life so I am an American at this
point teaching at Emory Law School but i
am from sudan and my cake is more as you
can expect because of where I am Who I
am is more activist and contesting than
is currently I hope it is color enough
but I don't think it's going to be as
curly as Luke's presentation I thought I
might just simply say I agree with
everything he said and sit down but but
there is a pot that I would like to have
good I'm okay so I'll be more specific
about Islam and to stop this of course
I'm sure that it is something that you
all think about what is cherry we came
here in this day of Sharia DC area that
and I would start by by that term and
the concept of it hopefully in order to
clarify what I think is a paradox in the
idea of Sharia I self plan in terms of
the modern and ancient and then I will
touch on the Arab Spring and what's
going on now in the middle years I hope
that will be helpful in trying to
understand or to untangle ampac what's
happening and then I will touch on the
question of Islamic State on politics
and then finally conclude maybe with the
u.s. in relation to the Arab world as
opposed to a relation to the Muslim
world which are very different places so
the point Ferris about Sherea Sherea is
simply the totality of the religious
obligation of a Muslim it is just simply
about every normative aspect or
understanding that the Muslim has I'm
not lying is a
paying a Sharia requirement sort of
earning your living or your livelihood
honestly is a shitty a prospective
fasting the month of Ramadan praying
five times a day so it is it is
everything that a Muslim is supposed to
do am be from articles of faith and
believe I'm cumin and religious practice
to social etiquette son would take it
also to think in terms of its
implications for the political and the
public yes but that is not all of what
it is in fact that is not most of what
it is or know what it has been
historically so as such it is a very
complex a very amorphous idea so you can
think of Sharia as a concept as an idea
of the divine command or the Mayan
guidance which by definition must be
immutable and then think of Sharia as
inherently unnecessarily a human
understanding of the divine which means
that it cannot be immutable and that is
the paradox I mean that as a Muslim
myself I look to Sharia for guidance in
the certainty of what God has ordained
because God knows best I'm got i decreed
that this is the way I should behave
this is the way I should think this way
should should should that but the
reality of course is that it is my
understanding of what God hath decreed
that is accessible to me there is no way
of understanding comprehending the
divine except through the agency of
human beings so but the divine cannot
remain divine what once it enters human
comprehension experience and it is
irrelevant until it enters human
comprehension experience that's what i
mean by the paradox so people look for
certitude in dividing mutability whereas
the only way that we can access that is
through human fail ability and as such i
think that very much the very much well
what what temperature Luke has talked
about in terms of the the ancient in the
modern whatever the modern
at any point in Muslim history it was
always a struggle between sort of a
fantasy of immutability and a reality of
confess ability of what Sharia Camille
and so on now another idea to present
here also is that that God made the
world too so whatever the world is is
God's creation and as such it is
integral to revelation revelation is not
just simply in description it is in life
and that is how I think relation has to
be understood constantly over time not
as an as an abstraction that is beyond
life it is in fact in inherent and
integral to life as we know it and
experience it so the changing world is
as much of the divine as the revelation
is of the divine and that's where I
think that we continue with the paradox
just to present briefly the idea of the
notion of Muslim in Arabic is called the
heat which is monotheism they believed
that there is only one God and that God
is the only actor or the ultimate actor
this idea of the of the God as the sole
ultimate actor and that human agency is
a two rather than an original author of
behavior that's a very fundamental idea
in the Muslim sort of intellectual
history and Theological history and that
I DM is that whatever we have to deal
with it is God who is dealing with it
through us through our experience for
our agents as human beings so that's one
idea or set of ideas now shifting to the
so-called Arab Spring because that's how
we make this sort of abstractions of the
divine and immutability and this and
that relevant to current events one idea
i would like to present about the Arab
Spring is the idea of course of calling
it the Arab Spring evokes images of
Eastern Europe
29 and that is both sort of we should
remember that only a metaphor that the
problem is with evoking images of
Eastern Europe or another place or even
the American Revolution as I will do in
a minute it's only a metaphor to try to
talk about fundamental transformative
moments but we should not expect similar
dynamics or similar outcomes because
time and place and everything else is
different so there is a limit to how
motif Oracle one can get or how little
one can get the idea that i would like
to present about arab uprisings is the
notion that rebellions mature into
revolutions over time and through
process that every revolution started as
a rebellion some rebellions make it into
revolution some don't but there is no
revolution that was not a rebellion to
start with including the American
Revolution the French Revolution the
so-called Soviet revolution that the
American Revolution sadar the rebellion
and could have ended as an opinion I
mean I think what what the King was
George or someone if she was if he had
responded in the right way probably this
would have ended and the British the
loyal subjects of the British crown in
North America would have continued to
remain loyal to the crown that's my sort
of course we can always is speculate as
what might have happened otherwise but
the point is that it did not start as a
revolution and was not predetermined to
be a revolution it became a revolution
by the action and choices that people
made over time interacting with the
world as they know it and as they
experience it that is the perspective of
multiplayer to the Arab uprisings or
rebellious to think of them as
revolutions in the making and that's why
I think it's misleading to predict or or
immediately say that they are not going
to succeed or they're going to think we
don't know yeah they might or might not
I mean I'm
I brought with me a New York Times orbit
of a few days ago about the weak
foundations of Arab democracy we don't
really know I'm really honest I think we
should be modest and scientific and
currently in trying to analyze
situations on their own terms in their
own history and context rather than
predicting outcomes immediately whatever
the outcome is my third point is that it
would have to deal with the ambiguity of
the notion of Islam State on politics
and on this at this is one of the my
bots with this looks remarks in that I
do make a distinction between the state
and politics and I argue that Islam and
the state have always been separated
differentiated at least there is no such
thing as an Islamic estate never has
been historically conceptually it is not
possible historical it never happened
but also that there is an inherent
connectedness between Islam and politics
and I would presume to say between all
religions our politics because release
believers act politically as believers
they don't sort of step out of their
sort of living skin to add and as
political ages and then come back to
their to be Christian or Jewish or
otherwise so the point I think it helps
to make a distinction between Islam and
the state is lemon politics to argue for
what has been I argue historically the
case that Islamic the state cannot be
United the state is a politically real
situation that is incapable of having a
religion it is incoherent to speak of an
Islamic state there is no particular
quality that is verifiable over 40 s it
is Islamic for the state to be that
argument and i'm sure that jen will soon
get to get me with my phone limit some
point so let me four minutes so let me
conclude by saying that I think that
helps in trying to understand how
different Muslim societies have to
struggle with these ideas for from the
rental fact of the transformative Empire
of colonialism I often find I'm an
American audiences in American scholars
there is a real lack of appreciation of
the profound impact of colonialist in
Africa in Asia and just to take the
point that the sort of estates that
Muslims have to live with now are
totally alien to their historical
experience they are European states
which have been imposed through
colonialism so it is really not
surprising and in fact if we completely
expected that they'll have to struggle
with adapting their social and cultural
and normative resources and experiences
to this new reality and it's a very
recent view reality it's only over the
last 60 70 years that these states have
been made out of colonial rule into
so-called modern state food so the
struggles with that is to be expected
and part of that is terribly have to be
the pressure of coming to terms with
what does it mean to be Muslim in the
modern and whatever modernity is
obviously at one point I would take
issue is is the notion of the
Enlightenment I think the point was made
that we should not give up on it I'd
rather do that with all due respect
because the Enlightenment gave me
colonialism in Africa all European
powers became colonial powers after day
enlightenment in fact driven by the
Enlightenment so the Enlightenment was
for Europeans but was not r Africans and
for that reason I would question whether
we can retain it as such the final point
i'll conclude ways is to say that i
would like for us to reflect on the
relationship between the right of states
and the Arab world and the United States
and the Muslim world and these are
different places Arabs make about twelve
percent of the total population of the
world of the Muslim population of the
world that is more than eighty eight
percent of Muslims live outside the
Middle East they are in fact more Muslim
in sub-saharan Africa then there are
Muslims in all of the Middle East but
yet in in our public imagination and our
discourse we tend to identify Islam with
the Middle East so much that we can we
fail and I think to our disadvantage and
to our detriment we fail to acknowledge
the profound historical depths and
diversity and complexity of what it is
to be Muslim globally India is the
second largest Muslim country in the
world but Darwin Muslims in India than
they're Muslims and any other country
than Indonesia and yet we never think of
India as a secular democratic state as a
state inhabited by the second largest
Muslim population in the world and what
is the experience of Indian Muslims they
have been part of the secular state of
the democratic process of the
transformation of India over the last 60
years so why why do fail to acknowledge
that reality and deal with it
appropriately that will be the final
Rima karmic so therefore I'm saying that
as a Muslim I am of the modern but my
modernity is integral to my sense of
understanding of the ancient I do not
pretend to discard the ancient but only
to redefine it thank you very much